my brother benji
that's where this whole rmc [ __ ] came
from
your brother benji
break down the rmc meaning and like kind
of the reason
for real money counter for anybody who
don't know real money counter yeah real
money counter yeah and like i said it's
from my brother it's from my brother
benji
he uh
he got locked up he had to go away for
some years
i'm sure he's proud though oh no hell
yeah i talked to him down there every
day you know he
he very proud
i'm just telling like when he when he
see he was the rapper
i never really wanted a rapper like i
always been around it but like i used to
dance dibble and dabble with him mm-hmm
but i'm
just like he was the main one you feel
me so like when he got locked up and i
started [ __ ] with this [ __ ] like i
ate he had no name for the long because
i was just mike right i'm just like
[ __ ] put the rmc on top of it all
broke down you feel me nice job and like
when i when we started this [ __ ] bro me
or rio
we never expected this [ __ ] to get this
big
what was the for you do you remember
like the moment or the song or the music
video where things started to like
really change for you as far as like
yeah it really it was the first million
views bro when [ __ ] was like
[ __ ]
do you remember when that was like what
song that was like the first time you
guys hit a million
see the crazy thing yeah
the first video that mia rio ever shot
did a million views that's [ __ ] crazy
so i let you know like it should it's
called lucid nightmares like we're we're
onto something right away
it was it was really mind-blowing bro
like what the [ __ ] well because most
people
it takes them like
a very long time you know we was already
getting like 10
10 20k 30k that was already because i
was like damn [ __ ] 20 000 people 30
000 people
but a million money
that's different man
it was like [ __ ] then not even that then
we came with back here back in with
craigs another million plus views like
[ __ ]
we're onto something like this [ __ ]
might yeah
then we dropped dumb and dumber oh that
took us off
that started that started the rocky ship
right there yeah the joint project
it was up